malgré un travail acharné des pompiers à
landiras la surface de feu continue de
s'étendre dans ce contexte les
évacuations se sont poursuivies dans la
nuit comme ici dans cet hôtel de la zone
commerciale de la teste de buch l'ordre
d'évacuation est arrivé vers 23h30 c'est
un camping mythique qui est aujourd'hui
réduit en cendres le camping des flots
bleus fait partie des cinq camping au
pied de la dune du pilat qui ont été
touchées par les incendies qui ravagent
la zone depuis une semaine franck dubosc
a posté un message pour témoigner de sa
tristesse comme le réalisateur fabien
ontoniente est un coup dur pour le
propriétaire de celui ci le footballeur
mathieu valbuena
c'est avec une grande tristesse parce
qu'on est très très belle région la dune
du pilat et est connu comme en france
dans le monde rendu aussi donc le tien
besoin d'être conçu mais moi aussi
voilà
c'est comme si j'étais un peu ensemble
on a tous fait entre 40 et entre 30 et
50 largage donc ça doit approcher les
306 des belles journées ces deux
journées mais c'est un feu qui méritent
même plus d'avions que ça nous
régressons seuls neuf canadair quatre
dash vol la maintenance assurée par
l'entreprise privée s'habille la
technique n'est pas au niveau il y à 16
commandeur de bord alors que 22 sont
nécessaires la france l'europe devrait
commander des avions des équipements en
nombre suffisant car ce type de méga
feux vont continuer de se produire
malheureusement il n'ya pas neuf
canadair que vous l'avez évoqué il n'ya
pas neuf avions il ya 21 avions et 35
hélicoptères nous avons la plus grande
flotte européenne la plus grande flotte
européenne de lutte contre le feu s'il
faut davantage de moyens il y en aura
davantage alors il est déjà prévu qu'il
y en ait davantage puisqu'on a programmé
d'ores et déjà des investissements
supplémentaires dans les cinq ans qui
n'avait 7 milliards d'euros c'est le
montant de l'offre publique d'achat du
gouvernement pour détenir 100% d'edf
l'état détient déjà 80 4% de
l'entreprise on a déjà commencé moi je
veux rappeler ce qui a été engagé dans
le cadre du plan de relance ce prêt de 3
milliards d'euros qui ont été mis par
exemple pour renforcer renforcer
l'isolation thermique des bâtiments
publics et notamment ceux des
collectivités locales moi j'ai proposé
qu'on nomme cette loi des miettes et
beaucoup de carbone vraiment ça
n'améliore pas la situation ça ne fait
même qu aggraver la situation qui génère
notre problème enfin si vous continuez à
émettre du carbone alors l'essence
continuera à augmenter c'est aussi
simple que ça vous avez la grande
distribution par exemple les centres
commerciaux qui ont annoncé un plan
massif qui devrait permettre de réduire
jusqu'à 40 % les consommations d'énergie
ça va de éteindre la lumière des
enseignes quand elle n'est pas utile
jusqu'à revoir la température à
l'intérieur de l'hypermarché surchauffe
à l'assemblée nationale depuis deux
jours des heures de passes d'armes entre
la france insoumise qui rejette toute la
loi pouvoir d'achat et le rassemblement
national qui se montre plus constructif
l'assemblée nationale elle est d'une
certaine manière et bien
bousculé par ces nouvelles méthodes de
la france insoumise outrance ignominie
excès polémique ils vont chercher des
coups de com refusant les petits pas
pour faire votre cirque vous faites
honte à la classe des travailleurs et
vous faites honte à cette assemblée qui
a besoin de rentrer de l'argent français
dans la forme l'invectivé permanente
l'insultent on l'a encore vu ce week-end
je crois que ça abîme au fond notre
démocratie et ça fait d'ailleurs le jeu
des députés du rassemblement national
c'est vrai qu'on a vu le ministre bruno
lemaire disparaissent de l'hémicycle
mais il peut se rassurer puisqu'il a son
sosie vocal en la personne de monsieur
tanguy d'accord pour le compromis
d'accord pour trouver des solutions mais
hier rien nous n'avons eu aucun
amendement y compris donc d amendement
de repli comme nous les appelons pour
pouvoir essayer de gagner quelques
avancées ici pas de surf au programme
mais un mariage bien arrosée
[Musique]